luego de la esperanza por el rescate de
los cuatro niños indígenas desaparecidos
durante 40 días en la amazonía
colombiana familiares y participantes de
la operación Esperanza revelan más
detalles de la búsqueda
porque para nosotros es el último
elemento que Dios no dejó para poder
sobrevivir a cualquier tipo de
supervivencia en temas de vida la
sabiduría ancestral como es nombrado el
conocimiento milenario de los pueblos
indígenas fue esencial para el éxito de
la misión según los comandos especiales
de las fuerzas militares que trabajaron
en conjunto con la guardia indígena un
acto inédito en la historia de
operaciones militares en Colombia el
pueblo ubitoto originario de la amazonía
colombiana sabe moverse por la espesa
selva donde los niños estaban
desaparecidos luego el accidente aéreo
lo cargamos a ellos durante dos horas al
hombro a la espalda
nosotros sin trocha ni nada haciendo
picas cargamos a dos horas pero la ardua
labor de los indígenas que participaron
en el rescate tuvo consecuencias algunos
de ellos enfermaron de malaria la
familia de los niños le pide al gobierno
colombiano que atienda a los rescatistas
le pedimos
enérgicamente al gobierno nacional
atención especial para los compañeros
indígenas Quienes se encuentran enfermos
por accidentes sufridos en la búsqueda
la familia de los menores señala que los
niños se encuentran en buen estado de
salud pero que por el momento no van a
permitir visitas Hasta que el proceso de
sanación de los menores termine en su
totalidad